first of all humbug doing good hanging
in there it's a it's a incredible to be
able to reliving losing memories first
you have the reality of the thing that
happened on 26 11 then you relive as
actors and then while talking about it
all three of these things need sincerity
and honesty and that's what is important
I think I want to start by saying how
tremendous this film is it is so
powerful and it's a for me it obviously
is a very tough watch but it was so
rewarding to watch I learned so much for
the two of you talk a little bit about
the experience of making this movie
because I would imagine that as actors
this must have been a very very tough
shoot I mean for me it was traumatizing
we're constantly bombarded with bullet
sounds and you're sort of living through
the in the footsteps of people who've
experienced extreme horror and trauma
and it was tough but what came out of it
was incredible a sense of gratitude for
every moment that you're alive this hope
that we can do better and that when
we're faced with world adversity it can
bring out the very best in us and to
live every day in the moment and and to
have you know be grateful for your loved
ones and it was just highly educational
and life-changing for me it was
traumatizing and it was tiring and it
was lonely at the end of the film and
everyday at the shoot I felt lonely I
felt sad and but next morning I thought
it was it again a new morning and that's
what the film is all about it makes you
feel sad jolted it makes you takes you
get gets you out of your own comfort
zone but you also discovered there are
ordinary in Ordinaries there are
extraordinary people there are people
who may not look like heroes but are
actual heroes in life whether it's chef
or whether it's the hotel staff or
whether it's ordinary people that's what
is gratifying but it was mentally
exhausting and when actors like to say I
was exhausted while doing this over
no it lingered on for a long time one of
the things about the film is I think it
does such a brilliant job at showing all
the facets of what happened here and how
the terrorists were just prime targets
for rattle radicalization from where
they came from I'm sort of talked about
how the film does that it just shows so
many different light well I think it's
important to realize that radicalization
is born out of abject poverty and also
really terrible education systems where
people are not being educated to know
better or to know what's going on in the
world so they this sense of otherness
and to treat people like less than human
is something that is born out of poverty
and brainwashed and people who are
brainwashed to believe a certain
ideology and extremism it's this film is
really anti-extremism and extremism can
be can take any you know form and it's
not confined to any specific religion or
you know faith and I think that's the
beauty of the film is if we can find the
root of something then surely we can
find a solution to it yeah I think that
I think it will not summed it up
brilliantly it's important that I think
human beings are born I always believe
upon as nice normal people as nice
people there is a goodness in every
everybody and then what life does to
them
changes that this film does show
different aspect of every every every
human being every person whether it is a
terrorist or whether it is a victim but
having said that I think it spreads more
than that it spreads an element of love
an element of togetherness and and it
brings out a compassion in you I think
that compassion is very important when
you watch the film it it depends on you
what you want to take away from the film
but what will you take away from the
film is a sense of togetherness that yes
these incidents should not happen but
then there is somebody to take care of
you I think this is Anthony's
directorial debut he obviously made a
few shorts but talk a little bit about
collaborate collaborating with him
because I think he did such an amazing
job
as soon as a force anthony is as an
onslaught sometimes but with onslaught
of goodness of compassion of intensity
he had recorded this gunshots and he
will not tell us that when he is going
to play them in the middle of the scene
suddenly we will boom boom and things
like that and he will constantly be
there whether it was one line ADR his
intensity as his passion is so amazing
and his detailing I was a little
skeptical when I discovered that the
film is is being made by an foreigner
it's an Indian situation but when he
narrated to me the whole thing and his
passion it was infectious I was very
proud that Anthony is making this film
I think authenticity is that people ask
me all the time
can a man write for a woman for example
and I think yes everybody can write for
anybody but the point is do you listen
do you listen to the people who actually
experienced something do you listen to
the people of that country do you are
you open to being educated and I think
Anthony is all of those things and he
was so open to learning and he did
extensive research and so for me as his
non-indian Assante a factor because of
that not because you know so there are
some people who just don't do the
research and they may be from the same
country or they may be and now he's a
half Indian it's lots of things in Indy
yeah one of the things that I think
again I keep on complimenting him but
I've seen a lot of movies and one of the
things that I think this film does so
brilliantly is that it does not
Telegraph anything that's gonna happen
you are on the edge of your seat the
entire film where you don't know what's
gonna happen and I would imagine that's
what people were really going through
there that's real life because that's
what the viewpoint of the film is from
the viewpoint of the people inside the
Taj the guests and the staff and they
didn't know what was gonna happen
yeah and they were not annoying and
there's a friend of mine who were the
general manager of Taj at that time and
he had caught his family his wife and
two young kids to stay in the hotel just
like that and they both all three of
them got killed and so when you go into
the movie to watch the film after 15
minutes you are inside the hotel
and it's happening to you even though
you are in the audience but that's where
the brilliance of Anthony comes in and
and I'm happy that it's it's important
to be jolted sometimes because when
you're jolted you will you start
thinking and you are a concern in this
very crowded life of ours stays a little
longer than it should my last question
for you guys is just talking about
filming in Mumbai I know you're from
Mumbai I'm curious what it was like
being in the city making something like
this it had such a powerful effect on
all the people that lived there I mean
to me it was a matter of respect you
have to respect the people who went
through it you have to respect the
locals and their story their privacy
sometimes there's some a lot of the
people who experience this we're not
public figures most of them were not and
so that's why a lot of these characters
are composite or amalgamations of real
life people who experience this and for
me experiencing Mumbai was both
beautiful and jarring because you see
abject poverty and extreme wealth in the
same place and and so in that sense the
Taj served as a microcosm of the greater
world but we I was happy that we shot
the interiors in us on a set in had lid
because we were focused we were together
for me to come back to Mumbai and start
shooting I was a little to me a little
time to get back into chef Oberoi's
character because my family was there my
friends were there the familiar but it
revived my memories of how resilient the
city of Mumbai is how amazing the people
of Mumbai are that they resurrected this
whole hotel back into its functioning
situation within nine months it was
completely devastated ruined finished
and when you go there today except for
the fall of all the victims who were
killed and that thing there is nothing
that you can say that this hotel was
once attacked he both did such a great
job thank you so much for your time
thank you
you